over the weekend the libertarian-leaning
Kok Network hosted a Rocky Mountain
retreat for donors and political leaders
well they use the occasion not to
amplify and cheer the president's
policies but to decry them 82 year old
Charles Koch has taken the reins of the
network he released this video in
advance of the retreat now he claims
opportunities in the global marketplace
are creating anxiety and the loss of
jobs at home in response we're seeing a
rise in protectionism for countries
organizations and individuals are trying
to protect themselves from these changes
they're doing whatever they can to close
themselves off from the new hold on to
the past and prevent change this is a
natural tendency but it's a destructive
form destructive let me tell you about
destruction sir one could also make the
argument that's selling out American
workers in offering up our industries in
our marketplace to the gods of globalism
is also pretty destructive now the cokes
have become billionaires by building and
buying amazing companies they're really
smart guys from Stila lumber and nylon
manufacturers over the last 20 years
they have grown their wealth by focusing
in large part on global operations and
some of that includes outsourcing jobs
and relocating plants overseas today
coke has a presence in 50 countries they
employ nearly a hundred and twenty
thousand people only 65,000 of those
people are in the United States
now look god bless them but America
shouldn't be facilitating the
outsourcing of jobs either through
really lame policy like regulation or
through poorly negotiated trade deals
and don't get me wrong the cokes have
done some great work on tax reform and
stuff like deregulation and also in the
area of education last year they spent
ninety million dollars on university
programs and
they're committed to expanding their
support for K through 12 education I
have a question for you
how effective will their education
efforts be if Americans enter a world
where China dominates most major
industries including the areas of stem
science technology and so forth
including things like artificial
intelligence we can't just look the
other way while China and a lot of other
countries by the way game the global
trading system and rack up huge trade
surpluses also of course IP theft unfair
subsidies and so forth any fair-minded
person would have to agree now with what
the White House economic adviser Larry
Kudlow a free trader himself said over
the weekend people say well president
Trump's tariffs are damaging this that
and the other thing I say don't blame
President Trump he inherited a
completely broken world trading system
including a World Trade Organization
most particularly China but not only
China
okay he's trying to fix it now remember
the cokes supported that job and
sovereignty killing trans-pacific
partnership and the NAFTA agreement that
both and of course bush Obama and until
the campaign at least Hillary championed
the coke Network like the rest of the
GOP old-guard is positively furious with
Trump's use of tariffs to level the
playing field in fact they announced
last month that they've committed to a
multi-million dollar multi-year campaign
to oppose what Trump's doing on trade I
have a question though why would they
want to lock us into these never-ending
trade deficits when the president's
efforts so far are actually bearing
fruit we saw what happened with the EU
last week South Korea already
renegotiated their deal and watch what
happens in the next few weeks with both
Mexico and China it's gonna be really
good meanwhile American workers and even
farmers some of them have been caught in
the crossfire of Trump's tough trade
battle with China but they're standing
by the president why well I think that's
kind
why would they say well they like that
he's fighting for them even if it hurts
their interests in the short term I'm a
good American I believe that we all have
to have to toe the line so you're okay
with bearing the brunt of these tariffs
am I willing to take my lumps for the
better you know for the benefit of the
entire country yes I first I am you're
willing to weather the storm for a
certain amount of time but how long is
too long well the Spanish memory says to
the death oh I love that well don't you
want that kind of deep sense of
patriotism they want to make money
obviously but they're also deeply
patriotic Americans and they're willing
to take that hit I think the cokes can
learn a lot from those regular Americans
and what they said that I love that tape
Trump's immigration plan by the way also
displeases the old guard and the GOP
that big Republican donor class now why
why are they so fixated on that because
they love the flood of cheap labor into
our market but Trump sees the border and
enforcement in the whole deal at our
southwest border very differently and he
articulated it today our countries have
learned through hard experience that
border security is national security
they are one and the same arguments of
national security and culture are
totally lost on the billionaire set but
for most Americans these are major
concerns
now the Koch Network is taking it a step
further they're now going so far as to
financially punish some politicians who
are supportive of the President's agenda
they announced today that they will not
be supporting gops North Dakota Senate
candidate Kevin Cramer who's trying to
unseat Democrat Heidi Heitkamp now
what's the COPE reason for that well the
Republican candidates supported Trump on
both trade and immigration at that
confab I was mentioning earlier in
Colorado Charles Koch made a big deal
about quote uniting people who were
previously divided but what does that
mean like how
how are these latest retaliatory efforts
actually doing that Trump is the one
uniting people for all the talk of
divisive nosov and Joy's in 88 percent
approval rating among Republicans
according to The Wall Street journal/nbc
poll only george w bush in the immediate
aftermath of 9/11 sought support like
that but the koch network and others
talk a good game about unity embracing
change and seizing opportunities but
when a president comes along who's
actually embracing a new path something
different on behalf of the american
people let's try a new thing now the
coax and the globalists just have their
blinders on they won't have any of it I
had to laugh when in the AP feature on
the Koch retreat it said the following
Democrats who invested extraordinary
time and resources into attacking the
Koch brothers in recent years conclude
that at least in the area of Trump the
billionaire industrialists are no longer
the left's number one enemy oh yeah
that's funny how that works
that's because Republicans lacked a
leader for so many years that the cokes
were the only game in town
but now the left has a new enemy it's
Trump and they're resisting him at every
turn
sadly the cokes are too often joining in
their ranks like the bushes the Koch
brothers did not support Donald Trump in
2016 think about that
but they have certainly reaped the
benefit of Trump's thriving economy I
like to prepare to take all their
profits that they made over the last two
years and what donated to Elizabeth
Warren cuz that's gonna be great for
their businesses do you think they're
gonna actually give them a better deal
and the things that they believe in tax
reform regulation and so forth what a
pity if the cokes and their well-heeled
donors miss the opportunity to support
the president and be a part of the
America first unity that people believe
in and that's the angle